[Music]
after two weeks of camping near the
white sands of new mexico i decided to
head back out west to explore an area
that bordered the southeast corner of
arizona
it felt remote and for three days the
world seemed quiet calm and completely
at peace
i would have stayed longer but nathaniel
and i had a photo assignment that was
location specific so it wasn't long
before i was back on the road headed for
tucson
[Music]
on the way nathaniel surprised me with a
night at roomland vineyard and it was
[Music]
on
perfect
our house our dreams
we were dancing on a wider breakfast it
seems
[Music]
uh
[Music]
here
[Music]
i spent the next week camped out in
tucson mostly working i had a few
photography projects to shoot and also
wanted to get started on a new video
since so much time had passed since my
last post
somewhere in there our friends michael
and priya from washington happened to be
passing through and drove out to camp
atlas
where they're like patrolling and
they're like
no
[Music]
good boy this is this guy's dad
so 16 mix is like the youngest
that any dog can be like he tries to get
up there sometimes there's a few times
he just like
does that
and he can't do it yet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
atlas
[Music]
honestly like
probably my favorite
the toilet is my favorite oh my god i
hate peeing out but it's the scariest
thing i always feel like i'm going to
get bit on my ass like as soon as
they're like squat diaphragm's going to
bite me and i was like
[Music]
just like not all are the exact same
size right
the sugar cane
[Music]
after a week in tucson we headed north
to sedona for another work project
there's sedona
out there
there's nathaniel
we're trying to find
a unique trail up
in these rocks
and it's like a playground there's
so many places around here to just hike
around
so pretty
[Music]
when
road 525 was a zoo but luckily we found
a remote spot with service to camp for
the week we spent the rest of our time
hiking scouting shooting and editing we
were there for seven days but it seemed
like only a day had passed before we
were packing up again and heading south
ahead of a winter storm
[Music]
[Music]
i'm always surprised by how quickly the
time passes
i tend to view the winter months as a
chance to slow down and take it easy
this winter i even considered renting a
couple month long airbnbs
but
that just hasn't happened
i've been happy being out here on the
road and suddenly it's april and soon it
will be may and i will have been out
here for four years
i sometimes wonder what my life would be
like now if i hadn't decided to move
into my suv
part of me thinks i would still just be
dreaming of taking that leap telling
myself i'll do it one day
i never imagined to be out here for so
long and yet here i am
i keep waiting for the urge to stop and
call someplace home
but it just hasn't happened yet
in many ways the road has taught me that
home isn't really a place anyway
it's something you carry within wherever
you happen to go
[Music]
[Music]
alright
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
we met up with mariah alice while camped
out in the superstitions and for a few
days the three of us caught up over
sunset walks and campfires hello
i love spending time with mariah the
conversations are so good and it's
always easy picking up right where we
last left off no matter how much time
has passed
plus how cute is finn
he looks so happy
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
sorting through footage from this past
month i realized that i forgot to film
kind of a lot of important moments
especially the in-betweens
turns out filming my life while actually
living my life are two very different
things
mostly i just forget to pick up my
camera
but i'm okay with it i like to think
these patchwork scenes and voiceovers
leave a little room for a mystery
and that the gaps in my timeline tell a
different kind of story one where i'm
present and
just plain living
so thanks for being here and i will see
you in the next one
[Music]
you